two days ago asa hutchinson the governor
of arkansas
uh vetoed a bill that would prevent
perverts from pumping little kids full
of cross-sex hormones he said that
this was very conservative he then went
on tv last night
to defend his decision why do you think
it's important for conservatives to make
certain that children
can block their puberty be chemically
castrated why is that a conservative
value
if you would tell us well first of all
you have parents involved in very
difficult decisions
you have physicians that are involved in
these decisions
and i go back to william buckley i go
back to ronald reagan the principles of
our party which believes in a limited
role of government
are we as a party abandoning a limited
role of government
and saying we're going to invoke the
government decision making
over and above physicians over and above
health care over and above parents
and saying uh you can't do you believe
it's healthy
william buckley and ronald reagan that's
who you're going to invoke
to defend chemically castrating kids i
do not want to presume to speak for the
dead
but from what i know about william f
buckley jr's political vision
it did not involve mutilating little
kids
and mutilating little johnny to look
like little jane
asa hutchinson here is not speaking for
buckley or reagan or conservatives
but uh asa hutchinson is speaking for a
dead
conservative consensus that has
dominated politics
for the last 20 years that we need to
purge from the republican party we need
to purge guys like him
from the republican party and we need to
play ball i'm michael knowles michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday comes from steven
reynolds
who who asks how would they react
if businesses were asking people if they
had hiv
before being allowed entry private
businesses have no
right to require me to fork over my
medical data well of course you know
now because kovid falls on one's part of
the political narrative now you're going
to be told that you have to prove that
you don't have covet or the variant or
the super duper variant or whatever
but if it were on another side of the
political narrative if it were hiv for
instance
this would be considered a crime against
humanity to ask people to prove
that they don't have the virus that
that's spreading rapidly at the time
my second favorite comment from
yesterday though i really liked this i
think it's very important to
to add to the the conversation about asa
hutchinson this is from mike on twitter
who says
if reagan was alive and saw that
interview he would have chain smoked a
carton of chesterfields
in complete despair of his party
he absolutely would have said i wouldn't
i don't want these jelly beans anymore
i need to smoke and drink if this man
will invoke my name well
well that's what we're gonna do we're
not gonna pump kids full of hormones
well you know if you want to be healthy
if you don't want to have this unhealthy
sort of nonsense running around if you
want to be healthy
you got to check out nutrasystem
nutrasystem is simple and convenient
with delicious meals delivered right to
your door with little to no meal prep
required that means
no shopping in busy grocery stores with
nutrasystem you can lose up to 18 pounds
in your first two months
the plan is clinically proven to put
your body in fat burning mode
and helps you achieve safe and healthy
weight loss nutrasystem helps you lose
weight
and learn how to keep it off they have a
top rated app called nume
for extra motivation to help you stay on
track you get
unlimited one-on-one coaching just a
really effective way
to lose weight i know a lot of my
friends they'll try lots of fad diets
you know and they won't eat one thing
or they'll only eat one thing for one
and it's just not sustainable
i don't think it's really healthy do it
do it the healthy way do it the right
way
order nutrisystem right now
i think a lot of people are especially
i'm living in nashville right now so all
i eat is chicken and biscuits all the
time
go to nutrasystem stuff tastes great go
to nutrasystem.com
knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s to get
50 off that is nutrasystem.com
speaking of playing ball
major league baseball has announced
officially it will move the all-star
game from georgia to
colorado all of this in the name of
racial justice and voting rights
this is ironic of course because
colorado
is much whiter than georgia and has much
more restrictive voting laws than
georgia too
that's kind of weird colorado is
86.9 percent white
and 4.6 black compared to georgia which
is 60.2 percent white and 32.6
black but but it gets even even crazier
uh because uh
they're moving to denver denver is three
quarters white nine percent black
really atlanta is uh
40.9 white and 51 black and of course
colorado has those tougher voter laws so
why are they doing it doesn't make any
sense does it it does
this is not about white people or black
people or any of the voting laws
this is about associating with certain
political parties
colorado has a democrat governor so it
doesn't matter how white the state of
colorado
is it doesn't matter how restrictive the
voting laws are georgia has a republican
governor
so it doesn't matter how black george is
or how lacks the voting laws are
this is about people associating
with different political parties it's
corporations saying
we don't want to do business with
republicans and we're going to make up
some excuse about voter laws or whatever
a race but it's really just
we don't like republicans we don't want
to do business with republicans this is
what harry's razors said the other day
harry's razors which had advertised on
my show
i don't know for about a year or
something like that then they dug up
some old clips some
some political operative or some random
twitter account
found a clip of me on candace owens's
old show
two years ago where i agreed with
something she said
and then harry's said that that our
values don't align
with with the conservative show what
they really mean is our values don't
align with conservatives so we'll take
your money your money is still green but
we hate you we don't like you we don't
want to be associated with you
maybe we should believe them maybe we
should just stop
doing business with these guys right
and that's the first level maybe we
should stop giving our hard-earned money
to companies and corporations and sports
leagues that hate our guts
but there's another level too which i
know some
more libertarian people on the right are
not happy to talk about but i think we
do need to talk about it
maybe we should start making it a little
bit harder for those corporations
to do business maybe we should use
politics
for political effect georgia democrats
right now are are pretty angry
at joe biden over this baseball fiasco
biden thought that he was going to go
along with his base and say yeah i hate
george w you got to pull the game out of
georgia but now the georgia democrats
are saying you just lost us 100 million
dollars buddy come on we were gonna make
a big show but not
actually kick them out so now joe biden
is changing his tune he was just asked
if
he would support the master's golf
tournament being moved out of georgia
here's his answer
i think that's up to the masters
look
you know
it is reassuring to see that
for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these new jim crow laws are just
antithetical to who we are there's
another side to it too
the other side to it too is when they in
fact move out of georgia
the people who need to help the most
people who are making
hourly wages sometimes get hurt the most
i think it's a very tough decision for a
corporation to make
or group to make but i respect them when
they make that judgment
and i support whatever judgment they
make but it's
the best way to deal with this is for
georgia
and other states to smarten up stop
it stop it stop it come on man that's
quite a change of tune
because just a few days ago he said that
he would encourage
major league baseball to get out of
georgia remember we played the clips on
the show yesterday what do you think
about the possibility of mlb moving out
of georgia yeah man i think that's great
come on man
absolutely that's these are new jim crow
laws
hey joe now all these georgia democrats
hate your guts well look
it's complicated and he he can't
directly contradict what he said
just a couple days ago so he needs to
just hold both ideas
in his mind at the same time he has to
say yeah these aren't jim crow laws
blacks are being systematically attacked
in georgia and prevented the right to
vote
but also maybe you should keep your
sports games there but
huh what's the argument i don't really i
don't really see the argument
and the point is yeah georgia come on
shape up
so he runs out of an argument he says
come on george you make this easier for
me come on just get rid of your
law which is less restrictive than the
law in colorado where the game is moving
the
build your own twitter republicans are
not going to like what i'm going to say
okay the squishes are not going to like
what i'm about to say but i don't care
what they think darn it
i think conservative public republicans
will like what i'm about to say
we need to make it uncomfortable for
companies to destroy our country
i don't like it when big government
threatens to destroy our country and
upend our culture and ruin our way of
life
i don't really like it anymore when big
corporations do that either
we need to use politics for political
effect
the left knows this they've done this
for a long time
now we're going to be told well if
conservatives use the political process
and the power that people give us well
then that makes us know
better than the leftists no no it
doesn't because we will be using it
for different purposes and while form
matters in politics
substance matters too it actually
matters what we're doing when
leftists wield political power to
destroy our country
that is a different thing than
conservatives wielding political power
to make our country better and they're
different worse
and better are not synonyms they are
they're actually polar opposites
and so i'm not saying that the
conservatives should wield political
power
arbitrarily and you know behave like
tyrants i'm not saying anything like
that
i'm just saying we should use the just
political power that has been given to
us legitimately by the people
to stop the destruction of our country
that is the most
basic lesson that anybody should take
from politics
but but unfortunately the right has
atrophied and its understanding of what
politics is over the last two or three
decades
this is the central topic of my upcoming
book speechless
controlling words controlling minds i
hope people read it before it's too late
that book is available for pre-order by
the way on amazon and you can you can
also pre-order an autographed copy
on premiere collectibles i think i'm
going to start sending copies for free
at least to some of these republican
governors and senators so that they
don't
start all becoming asa hutchinson in
arkansas
or something all becoming these squishy
weak liberals you know
one governor who is taking to heart what
we've just been talking about
is ron desantis down in florida ron
desantis understands that it's not
it's good to not give your money to
companies that hate you but also there
need to be consequences
when even allegedly private
organizations
try to destroy our country ron desantis
just spoke out against that hit piece
that was on 60 minutes about him where
they chopped it up and
made it look like he said something that
he didn't say rhonda santa said look
this was a ridiculous hit job and
moreover there's going to be
consequences
they cut out everything that showed that
their narrative was a piece of horse
manure
and it shows you how dishonest these are
smear merchants that's why nobody trusts
corporate media they are a disaster
in what they're doing they knew what
they were doing
was a lie i knew what they were doing
was a lie everybody here knows what they
were doing
is a lie they know that we know they're
lying and yet they continue to lie
and they lied and they lied and they
lied
we offered them the information and they
declined
to interview the key people because they
didn't want to let go of the narrative
well guess what there's going to be
consequences for that
we're not i know corporate media thinks
that they can just run over people
uh you ain't running over this governor
i'm punching back
there's going to be consequences that
speech that he just gave that brief
speech could have been a trump speech
the mannerisms were the same the wording
was the same ron desantis if he's going
to run in 2024
he's obviously running in the trump lane
this
idea that conservatives ought to be able
to use legitimate political power
that is a consequence of the trump
phenomenon of his candidacy and of his
presidency
that's a very good thing he has shaken
off the old
dead consensus that guys like asa
hutchinson
are still having the last gasps of
before he leaves office
ron desantis sees which way the wind is
blowing he's obviously moving in that
direction i think
a lot of republicans are doing that even
even
good old cocaine mitch mcconnell is
recognizing that
you know if you want to hear
which way where the politics is going
if you want to hear if you want to
listen very closely to say wait a second
what are the people saying
you should check out raycon's you know
when i want to rest my eyes and still
get the content that i'm looking for
i love raycon wireless earbuds
raycon wireless earbuds are they're just
an improvement over a lot of what you're
seeing in the market right now
no dangling wires no stems to get in
your way i'm not calling out any
products in particular they come in a
range of stylish color ways
they're always comfortable with a great
in-ear fit for a more discreet
look the best part as far as i'm
concerned raycon makes great sound
accessible to
everyone with wireless earbuds starting
at half the price of other premium audio
brands
and i don't i don't know how to put it
more bluntly raycon's just a superior
product to a lot of the more expensive
options out there on the market today
raycon's offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
here's what you got to do to get it
go to raycon dot com slash knowles
kenner wlas that's it
you'll get 15 off your entire raycon
order so feel free to grab a pair and a
spare
that is 15 off at buyracon.com knowles
buy raycon dot com
slash knowles it is not just ron
desantis in florida
who's saying we need to hold these
people to account it's not just
conservatives like ted cruz
it's not just people like josh hawley
even
mitch mcconnell who is the avatar
of the establishment right mitch
mcconnell recognizes
that the threat posed by woke
corporations
to our american way of life to our
political traditions to our
constitutional order
is just as grave as the threat posed by
big government mcconnell
issued a statement yesterday said from
election law to environmentalism to so
radical social agendas to the second
amendment
parts of the private sector keep
dabbling in behaving like a woke
parallel government corporations will
invite serious consequences if they
become
a vehicle for far-left mobs to hijack
our country
from outside the constitutional order
thank you
cocaine mitch oh that makes me just want
to
plant my face into a bunch of mcconnell
talcum powder and say
say hello to my little new political
philosophy
very very important stuff that
conservatives are growing
some cojones finally it's
you know it we've been talking about
this for a long time on this show and
people have said oh michael please
that's fringe that's radical no
it's everyone in the republican party
who matters right now who is doing
anything even remotely positive for
not just conservatives but therefore for
the whole country
recognizes this threat and the old
silly clean-cut dichotomy between the
public and the private sector we
now recognize to be much blurrier than
than
people have thought for the last 20 or
30 years
the idea here is to stand up for
america which means standing up for
americans
which means standing up for the american
way of life
over the whims of massive often
international
corporations with no national loyalty no
net loyalty to the country no loyalty
to you or me their countrymen and some
republicans are really irritated by that
so i think the ones that get which way
the country's going
the ones that get which way the country
should go the ones that have real
serious influence
they're they're on board with taking on
this challenge
and then there's liz cheney liz cheney
oh man the only republican in the house
to i think she's no she wasn't the only
republican but she was the only
republican in leadership in the house
to vote to impeach donald trump a second
time for what i don't know because they
didn't like the cut of his jib or
something
liz cheney is coming out really against
this way of thinking and
not specifically with regard to what
governor desantis
or senator mcconnell have said but with
regard to
a memo that came from representative jim
banks to
the minority leader in the house kevin
mccarthy who it was a very simple memo
it's long but i can sum it all up
in a little bit republicans are the
party of the working class
for a lot of the last 20 30 years
republicans have been the party of the
rich
and democrats have claimed the working
class and ordinary everyday americans
and now that has changed trump has
changed that in this in the same way
that ronald reagan changed the
republican party to
win win back more blue-collar workers he
said this is a good thing
and we should focus on that not just
because it's
politically advantageous but because
it's right it's good
we should not just sell our fellow
americans who work in
lower wage jobs we should not just sell
their future out to china
or to mexico or to some other country so
that we can boost gdp slightly
and tell them to you know go away and do
their drugs and maybe we'll cut them a
check or something every now and again
but
leave us alone while people on the
coasts make a lot of money
very simple document makes a whole lot
of sense liz cheney furious
according to politico she has argued
that the gop is not the party of class
warfare and that dividing society into
classes
while attacking the private sector is
neo-marxist
and wrong
class warfare cuts two ways
congressman cheney class warfare cuts
two ways now we're being told that if
you in any way stand up
for americans who work in manufacturing
for americans who work in rural areas
for americans who have had their jobs
shipped overseas because of intentional
trade agreements
that were signed by people who hold a
very specific political ideology
members of both parties by the way that
if you stand up for them you're
engaging in class warfare it's divisive
it's wrong it's marxist
you know when you tell those americans
to shut up when their jobs get shipped
overseas
that's class warfare 2. when you tell
americans
that that they need to let their towns
die
like a writer prominent conservative
writer did some years ago
that's class warfare it seems like class
warfare to me at least
when you tell people
that they have no right to discuss
economic policy that look we just
worship at the altar of the free market
capital f
capital m trademark over the t doesn't
look that free to me
but it's it's a a sort of contrivance
into creation
of a very narrow political ideology in a
certain political class
when you tell them they have no
constitutional or political right to
question that
that's class warfare cuts both ways
because economic policy is not simply a
matter of the private sector
and when woke corporations wield their
massive political power to push
awful narratives to fund blm terrorists
to
to turn the arms of governors
multiple republican governors to suggest
that it's perfectly fine to pump kids
full of hormones and have
boys use the girls room even most basic
questions like that
well that's not just a matter of the
private sector when when our country
gets destroyed
and and we're all prevented from
practicing our religion and speaking our
views and keeping our american way of
life
i don't think we're going to say well at
least our country was ruined by the
private sector and isn't that isn't that
wonderful
isn't that great thank you liz cheney
for allowing the private sector capital
p
capital s trademark over the r to
destroy our country i don't think so
i do not think so we are we we've
totally flipped this culture
upside down great example of this would
be in comic books you might imagine i'm
not a huge comic book fan
but i remember when the news headline
came out that
marvel comic books i guess it was hired
tom heezy coates
the race-hustling extraordinarily
overrated writer who he's a darling of
white liberals
who award him all sorts of prestigious
awards and
give him lots of money to talk about how
terrible america is and how
how black bodies to use his phrase are
horribly oppressed
when he uses that phrase black bodies i
always wonder i said you don't think
black people
have souls why do you keep using that
strange phrase black bodies so they
hired him to write the captain
america comic i said okay here we go
here we
can't wait for this one to come out well
it's out and i guess there's some
villain
in captain america called red skull
and he's a really bad guy you know and
uh in tonight's version
the red skull is jordan peterson
jordan peterson a mild-mannered
canadian professor and psychologist
whose most
outrageous statements are telling kids
to make their bed
and pursue truth and stand up straight
you know really kind of basic stuff if
you want to have a good flourishing life
he is now the villain and it's pretty
pretty clear you know
they they reference jordan's books and
the comics now they reference various
things that he said
we now in this country are being told
that truth is falsehood and right is
wrong
and good is bad that is that is not
simply a matter of free speech versus
censorship
or the public sector in the private
sector
that is a matter of one set of standards
the radical new standards competing with
the traditional standards in this
country that's really what the battle is
that is i should mention the topic of my
upcoming
book speechless the timing couldn't be
better on the one hand
i'm pleased that the book i have coming
out is about this very topic because
it's timely on the other hand i'm
utterly dismayed because this is all
happening really really quickly
and we're now being told that if you
want to clean your room and make your
bed and stand up straight and pursue
truth that you're an evil rotten nazi
we're being told this
not by big government we're being told
this by the culture by comic books
by woke corporations bad
bad stuff we need to push back and it is
just too weak folks to say well but we
can't exercise any political power
because if we exercise political power
that will make us no different than the
left
no it'll make us very different than the
left because we will be opposing
their standards we will be we will be
engaging in politics as
all successful political movements have
for all of human history everywhere on
earth
and i think some conservatives don't
have the courage to be successful they
don't want to they don't want to defend
the new standards because really they're
just liberals like asa hutchinson in
in arkansas really when it comes down to
it they're technocratic progressive
liberals who want to go a little bit
slower
well i don't think we should we have
time to do that
donald trump said he doesn't have time
for political correctness we don't have
time
to wait on that kind of stuff this is
happening
right now you know ben will be talking
on the show today about how the blowback
is coming on how there is a lot of
discontentment going on right now with
what the left is doing so check out
ben's show also check out candace's show
streams fridays at 9 pm eastern apm
central dailywire.com
you can also get the audio podcast
candace on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcast so if you need
some candice owens in your podcast feed
look no further
head on over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today i am told
i'm reliably informed she's going to
have a tremendous guest on the show this
week
handsome mellifluous just
charming i got you don't want to miss
this week's episode that's all i'm going
to say head on over to dailywire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
finally we're reopening the country
right isn't that great we're get we get
to see our family again
dr fauci's reign of terror is over it's
it's weakening at the very least
we can go do things we can go back to
work we have weddings we can go to
funerals we can
we can do the things that you need to do
as a society
but not so fast because now we are being
reliably informed
by the experts in the lab coats
talking through the mainstream media
that we can't reopen yet because there
are
double variants double mutant variants
and a fourth wave
stay home stay afraid
stay sheep say the mainstream media a
lot of attention on this rangers blue
jays game and it's not because of the
matchup on this brand new field
as many as 40 thousand five hundred and
eighteen fans
could pack this ballpark that would make
it the largest gathering of people in
this country
in more than a year but president biden
is already calling foul
this morning concerns about a double
mutant coronavirus variant in the u.s
the variant first discovered in india
now identified in the san francisco area
this is the first time this particular
double mutant has been found in the
united states and it was found here at
our stanford laboratory
this is covent cases across the country
climb and fears of a fourth wave are
growing
even as more than 106 million americans
have received at least one dose of the
vaccine it's kind of like a race
between getting people vaccinated and
the more people on a daily basis you get
vaccinated the better chance you have of
blunting
or preventing that surge that we're all
concerned
about how does anybody
take these people seriously anymore i
feel
like we are living in a comic book
double mutant they couldn't come up with
a less cartoonish
phrase than that it's a double mute stay
home keep listening to fouchy
i know you're all going out and you're
realizing everything's totally fine and
it's
it's normal and the public health people
don't have any credibility but you gotta
it's gonna be a triple mutant before you
know it goodness gracious by the way i'm
not i'm not even saying
i'm i'm not saying that there's no virus
i'm not saying that the virus
isn't dangerous to some people i'm not
saying that there aren't variants of the
virus
i'm not making any scientific point
i'm just making the political point that
we cannot live like this forever
and we should not live like this forever
since the beginning
of this epidemic i have ignored
basically all of the rules and the
guidelines
in narrow circumstances where i have to
wear a mask for instance
i do like on an airplane i will do that
usually i'll protest it by getting my
little nose out there that's my subtle
protest but you know
if i have to do it i have to do it i'll
make a prudent calculation that it's
better to go give the speech somewhere
than to not not fly and not wear the
mask but generally speaking
99 of the time i've completely ignored
all of the guidelines
i've never felt better does this mean i
can't get the virus no i can get the
virus does this mean i have no risk of
serious complications no i do
i'm making an informed risk assessment
and choosing to live my life if you told
me right now michael
you can live an extra year five years
10 years you can live an extra 10 years
if you only lock down don't see your
family
wear the stupid mask so that you muzzle
yourself in public and you can't see a
smiling face ever again
just do that and you can live an extra
10 years i would say no deal
i don't want to life is about more than
that the neurotic
fear of death that has taken over our
culture
because people are i guess afraid of the
dark
and they've utterly lost their faith and
they think very foolishly that they can
extend their lives forever and they're
never going to die
is an existential matter
by definition it's an existential matter
it's a real real threat
to the country because we're all
behaving
like neurotics like paranoiacs
like easily manipulable
children stop doing that live your life
as president trump said do not be afraid
do not live your life in fear of the
virus
you know what's going to happen after
the double mutant there's going to be a
triple mutant you know what's going to
happen after the triple there's going to
be a quadruple quintuple mutant virus
these are not scientific questions
there's there are new kinds of flu all
the time there's new kinds of all sorts
of viruses and
and diseases are you going to live your
life like this
that's not a scientific question exactly
that's a medical question
dr fauci has got some questions to
answer though on the scientific front
because
we were told by people like dr fauci
that if you
don't follow all the fouchy guidelines
if you lift
mandates and the mask mandates and the
indoor dining
if you lift it the cases are going to go
through the roof we're all going to die
and so what did texas do texas lifted
all the stupid mandates and what
happened
nothing that dr fauci predicted so
fouchy was brought on to msnbc
credit to the interviewer on msnbc said
hey dr fauci
looks like you were wrong do you have
anything to say about that if you go to
texas as you know it looks like 2019 the
restaurants and the bars are full and
open the ballparks are full
and yet we've seen cases and
hospitalizations since then continue to
tick downward
so what do you make of that as all of us
look around and sort of try to consider
how safe it is to get back to normal
life
yeah you know it's it can be confusing
because you may see a lag
and a delay because often you have to
wait a few weeks
before you see the effect of what you're
doing right now
you know there are a lot of things that
go into that i mean
when you say that they've they've had a
lot of
uh activity on the outside like ball
games
i'm not really quite sure it could be
they're doing things outdoors you know
it's
very difficult to just one-on-one one
compare that you just have to see in the
long range
i hope they continue to tick down if
they do that would be great but we've
been fooled before
we've been fooled before you don't say
dr
fauci and who did all the fooling listen
if anybody knows about fooling people
it's me dr fauci
wear the mask sheep dr speaking of
i'm not even just saying he got things
wrong i'm saying he said things that he
did not believe were true
remember when he said at the beginning
of the epidemic he said don't wear a
mask wearing a mask is bad it doesn't do
anything
it actually it might be worse if you
wear a mask because you'll touch your
face
so don't do it and then about five
seconds later he said now you all have
to wear masks
i said what changed and he explained his
reasoning he said well
at the time i knew that that i felt the
masks did work
at stopping the spread of the virus but
i felt there might be a mask
shortage so i wanted to reserve masks
for all the
public health people that i felt
deserved to have them and i didn't want
all you peasants to have the masks
so i told you that the masks don't work
so you wouldn't buy up all the masks but
now that i know we have enough masks
now i'm going to admit to you what i
believed all along which is that the
masks do work so now you have to wear
one
if you're going to admit to that kind of
dishonesty
what credibility do you have
we've been fooled before we have indeed
been fooled before opposition
to reopening the country at this point
is
it is a grift as it always has been a
grift
but at this point it's a totally
transparent rift
the los angeles teachers union those
brave souls
who promised they're going to return to
work sometime in 2057
the la teacher union is demanding
now that there's no argument virtually
every school is back in some
some capacity l.a teachers union holding
firm they say they won't return to work
not it's not until they clean the
classrooms it's not until they make
people wear the stupid masks or whatever
they won't return to work until they're
given
free child care for their own children
according to a report
from politico what
what does that have to do with the
coronavirus you're just trying to get a
an insanely generous perk of employment
as as a negotiation that very few of us
in the workplace have i don't get free
child care at my office
why are the la teachers supposed to get
free child care
these are government employees who are
paid by formerly by my taxpayer dollars
thankfully i'm out of that place
what is going on now is not a union
action to protect their members for
safety what is going on now is
effectively a strike
the la teachers union is going on a
strike not because of
a virus or a fear of getting the
sniffles they're they're going on strike
because they want to get a better
contract they want to get a better deal
they should have no right to do this
these government employees who
are paid relatively well certainly for
the work they're doing right now which
is bupkus
bupkus work for a decent enough salary
they should be given an ultimatum they
should be told
go back to work or lose your job
simple as that a former governor of
california
ronald reagan gave air traffic
controllers this ultimatum
when he was president the air traffic
controllers union
decided they want to get a better deal
and
they had had no right to do this they
were a government
union they had no right to go on strike
that's the law
law was very clear they went on strike
anyway and ronald reagan did not
say well you know okay maybe we'll give
just okay can you go back in six months
he said if you don't go to work in two
days you're going to lose your job and
that's that
i must tell those who fail to report for
duty this morning
they are in violation of the law and if
they do not report for work within 48
hours
they have forfeited their jobs and will
be terminated
clear enough to me this absolutely
should be the rule with the la teachers
union
it won't be because the advantage that
reagan had here well one is that he had
been a union president he had been the
president of the screen actors guild
so he knew how unions worked down to the
very
bottom also he
he was not in the pocket of the unions
the unions did not really like ronald
reagan some unions liked him but
but a lot of them did not because he was
a republican
and so it was not so hard for him to
oppose the unions for someone like gavin
newsom
who's fighting for his political life
right now or someone like the la mayor
or supervisors they are in the pocket of
the union so they can't fight them
this is part of why uh public sector you
know government unionization is so
uh so insidious is that in in the case
of a public sector
union the government is negotiating with
itself so there's no no incentive to
keep the prices down
because the the government is just
bribing the government union workers
with taxpayer dollars
to then go organize and then the unions
vote for those democrat politicians
makes for decent politics but it's not
great for the country
absolutely
they need to be opposed who's going to
do it
gavin newsom's not going to do it but
gavin newsom very likely i mean
almost certainly is going to be recalled
who's going to run against him well
there's one candidate
who is considering throwing his or her
hat
into the race that would be caitlyn
jenner
caitlyn jenner is reportedly
exploring a run for california governor
as gavin newsom faces this recall
i predicted this might happen some while
ago because
caitlyn jenner is wealthy very
well-known
republican uh could could create an
organization
and loves being on tv so obviously you
know this this could happen
what should we think about the
prospective governor caitlyn jenner
this would not be the first time that a
political leader has cross-dressed in
history
this would not be the first time this
actually happened at least one other
time
way back in ancient rome now the
the bad news here is that the political
leader who did that was
nero considered one of the worst rulers
ever in in human history
a nero who reportedly uh slept with his
mother and then murdered his mother
and married a freed slave and
nero himself dressed up like the woman
he was the bride in that
in that particular uh matrimony
and he was known for his kind of crazy
days-long orgies and rome burned under
his watch and he
he legendarily fiddled while that was
happening so you know we don't
okay we don't want another nero that
would not be good but the question does
become
would caitlyn jenner be better than
gavin newsom
obviously caitlyn jenner would probably
be pretty pretty weak on
the transgender issues but on other
issues he's pretty
pretty right wing at least relative to
california does the buckley rule apply
here should we vote for the most right
viable candidate
if we get newsom you're going to get all
the terrible policies
including all the terrible transgender
policies and with caitlyn jenner i guess
you'll get terrible transgender policies
but you'll get
decent enough other policies politics
sure is a messy business but
it certainly would be interesting to
watch no question about that
and i don't think conservatives should
just totally write this off
because gavin newsom is a bad
governor and we'd have to see if you
know if caitlyn jenner can articulate a
conservative position
i think caitlyn jenner's views on
transgenderism are much more
conservative than the current governor
of arkansas asa hutchinson
so it would be interesting to watch play
out
speaking of eccentric people in la
there recently was an awards show for
hollywood
you didn't watch it i know no one did
either
no one else other than i think the
actors themselves this was the screen
actors
guild awards and
as ever they're just trying to alienate
as many people as they possibly can
the winner of one of these awards jason
sudeikis
wore a radical uh political
shirt during the zoom awards from his
living room
that i think carries with it shows you
not just what's wrong
about hollywood but what is wrong more
broadly
in our politics jason sudeikis
who is some sort of actor i don't really
know what he was on i kind of recognize
his face
he won the screen actors guild
award and he gave a very nice little
speech and while he was giving his thank
you speech on zoom
he wore a shirt that said my body my
choice
take a listen and the actor goes too
jason sedakis ted lasso
man are you kidding me
wow thank you uh to to all of my fellow
actors
i want to thank my mom for uh bringing
me to
plays and musicals in kansas city every
touring company came through whether
it's fan of the opera or the cajon falls
uh i want to thank my dad for taking me
to go see movies
uh took me to go see beverly hills cop
when i was nine years old
i knew at that point i wanted to be a
black cop from detroit
um getting there and again i thank my
fellow cast mates
because they make me better because i
just again happy job
uh thank you again this is very
amazing appreciate it he's wearing a
shirt
defending abortion during his
acceptance speech and the first thing he
does is thanks his mom
you can't make that up if you put that
in a hollywood script
the producers would reject that they'd
say it's too on the nose that's too
ridiculous
but that's that's what's happening and
at no point did
jason sudaikis think that there was any
conflict here
this is one of the really insidious
effects of political correctness
is it makes you hold conflicting views
simultaneously reviews simultaneously
that's what george orwell would call
double think he said that by the way
the totalitarian regime that he
describes in 1984 relies perhaps most
importantly on doublethink
that is what we are seeing here we
should not fall into that trap
you know the issue with my body my
choice is that a lot of conservatives
putative conservatives use that line too
but not with regard to abortion but
they'll say you know look if if so
to go bring it back to the transgender
issue if if someone wants to mutilate
his body
then that's his right to do it my body
my choice that's not
that that's not a conservative point of
view i guess it's a libertarian point of
view but it's not a conservative point
of view
the conservative point of view is that i
don't own my body
i don't i didn't i didn't create my body
i'm not i'm not a creator i'm a
procreator but i'm not i
i didn't create my body i didn't choose
to be born into this world
my life was a gift i have some
responsibilities
to my creator to the moral order to my
fellow citizens and
you know i didn't choose how i came into
this world i'm probably not going to
choose how i left this world so i have
to be a steward of that and recognize
that i
am not all-powerful
you know whitaker chambers described
communism as the great alternative faith
of mankind
that began in the garden when the
serpent said to eve ye shall be as gods
we we we conservatives recognize we are
not gods
we are not entitled to do whatever we
want and actually that will undermine
government i will undermine
self-government
we we need to be a little clearer about
this
and i know it's hard and it requires
courage because for
20 years the past 20 years or so
conservatives have have
distilled their philosophy down to the
most shallow version of hey whatever you
want to do
do it just don't make me pay for it
that's not
conservative it's not coherent
it's not convincing it hasn't worked it
doesn't convince people we need to get
back to making actual
substantive arguments there's a good
good bit of news coming out of texas now
i said on the show last couple days i've
said
desantis is doing a good job and tate
reeves in
mississippi they're doing a good job at
the state level of saying
no we are not going to permit
vaccine passports and they've said
definitely no
as a state mandate and maybe we'll also
stop the private businesses from issuing
requiring vaccine passports too because
that's not merely a private matter
that's good and i said there's 27
republican governors in this country
they all need to go on the record
immediately a lot of them are
25 of them are pretty quiet so
just after the show maybe he was
listening governor greg
abbott in texas came out and he said
no vaccine passport mandate in texas
every day texans return to normalcy as
more people get the covet vaccine
in fact this week texas will surpass
13 million doses administered
those shots help slow the spread of
covet reduce hospitalizations
and reduce fatalities but
as i have said all along these vaccines
are always voluntary and never
forced government should not
require any texan to show proof of
vaccination
and reveal private health information
just to go about their daily lives
that is why i issued an executive order
that prohibits government mandated
vaccine passports in texas
we will continue to vaccinate more
texans and protect
public health and we will do so
without treading on texans personal
freedoms
great good i'm so glad to hear it thank
you governor abbott i'm glad that the
state of texas will not tread on
texans personal freedoms but that's
not enough it's a good start so i don't
want to discourage you
you need to go further you need to go
where i don't think any governor has
really said this on the record yet but
they they've been kind of testing the
waters and intimating this most notably
desantis
you need to say it's not just about the
state mandating it we're going to stop
private allegedly private companies
from requiring the vaccine passport too
we are going to stop
in mitch mcconnell's words what has
become a sort of parallel government
run by woke corporations i like a
thriving private sector
within certain boundaries set by our
american constitutional order
i really like that but i am not an
idolater
of the so-called private sector such
that
i would be happy if a handful of woke
international corporations
run our government effectively
determine how we're going to walk around
in the world
insist that i give them my medical data
and i show
what vaccines i've gotten before i can
go into a restaurant and have a
hamburger
no way buddy i i ain't doing that and so
i'm glad
governor abbott is doing this but he
needs to
follow which way the the politics is
going i think
finally people are waking up to this i
hope that
my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds wakes more people up
to this
when it comes out at the end of june and
in the meantime i hope conservatives get
much tougher we need
to play ball i'm michael knowles this
michael knowles show see tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matte
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show